en el vídeo anterior diseñamos un
experimento en el que teníamos una
medicina que pensamos puede ayudar a
controlar los niveles de azúcar en la
sangre de las personas buscamos algo que
pudiéramos medir como un indicador de
que los niveles de azúcar en la sangre
están controlados y la hemoglobina a1c
es lo que las personas miden en un
examen de sangre tenemos un vídeo sobre
esto en khan academy pero es una
medición del promedio del nivel de
azúcar en la sangre durante
aproximadamente un periodo de tres meses
y diseñamos un experimento clásico donde
tenemos un grupo de control y un grupo
de tratamiento y asignamos
aleatoriamente personas a ambos grupos
ya sea el grupo de control o al grupo de
tratamiento y para asegurarnos de que
ambos grupos no tengan un desequilibrio
en el caso del vídeo anterior un
desequilibrio en cuanto a la cantidad de
hombres con respecto a mujeres hicimos
lo que llamamos diseño de bloques donde
tomamos a estas 100 personas las
dividimos entre hombres y mujeres y
dividimos aleatoriamente a la mitad de
estas mujeres en cada uno de estos
grupos
lo mismo hicimos con los hombres
aleatoriamente asignamos la mitad de los
hombres a un grupo y la otra mitad al
otro grupo para que al menos tengamos
una distribución equilibrada con
respecto al sexo medimos los niveles de
hemoglobina a1c de todos los individuos
antes de comenzar el experimento después
esperamos tres meses en donde cada grupo
recibió el placebo o la medicina y
después vemos si hay una mejora
estadística en los niveles de
hemoglobina a1c este fue un diseño
clásico y bastante bueno de un
experimento también lo diseñamos de
manera de que los pacientes no supieran
si reciben el placebo o la medicina así
que es un experimento ciego y también es
bueno que ni las enfermeras ni los
doctores que estén administrando el
tratamiento tampoco sepan qué es lo que
están dando si el placebo o la medicina
así que es un experimento doble ciego
pero esto no significa que sea un
experimento perfecto en muy pocas
ocasiones tenemos un experimento
perfecto y es por eso que debemos poder
replicarlo otras personas deben de
tratar de probar lo mismo que hicimos
quizás de diferentes formas pero aún en
la forma en que diseñamos
el experimento existe la probabilidad de
que hayan variables ocultas que nos
puedan confundir aquí nos aseguramos de
que nuestra distribución de hombres y
mujeres fuera equilibrada en ambos
grupos pero quizá nuestro muestreo
aleatorio tuvimos una cantidad
desproporcionada de personas jóvenes en
el grupo de tratamiento y quizás las
personas jóvenes responden mejor al
tomar esta medicina
quizá cambia su comportamiento de otras
formas y quizá las personas mayores
cuando toman esta medicina comen peor
porque están confiados de que están
tomando medicinas que les va a ayudar a
controlar sus niveles así que podemos
tener estas variables ocultas estas
variables que nos pueden confundir como
la edad el país en el que viven y otro
tipo de cosas que solo con la asignación
aleatoria podríamos terminar con
características desequilibradas en estos
grupos una técnica para ayudarnos a
mitigar un poco esto es lo que llamamos
el diseño de pares igualados
diseño de pares igualados lo que
esencialmente nos ayuda a quitarnos este
problema de hacer diseño de bloques todo
este muestreo aleatorio en lugar de todo
esto lo primero que hacemos es asignar
aleatoriamente a estas personas en
alguno de estos grupos ya sea el de
control o el de tratamiento
hacemos este experimento medimos y
después hacemos otra segunda ronda en
donde hacemos el cambio de que las
personas que estaban en el grupo de
tratamiento ahora van a estar en el
grupo de control y viceversa así que
podemos extender lo que tenemos aquí nos
imaginamos que en los primeros tres
meses tenemos a la mitad de las personas
en este grupo de tratamiento y las otras
50 personas en este grupo de control
veamos qué es lo que pasa con sus
niveles de a1c y luego los cambiamos y
en primer lugar idealmente este es un
experimento ciego así que las personas
no saben a qué grupo pertenecen por lo
que la medicina y el placebo deben de
lucir idénticos y ahora este grupo
durante los siguientes tres meses serán
el grupo de control
así que toman la medicina en los
primeros tres meses vemos
es lo que ocurre con sus niveles de a1c
y después estarán tomando el placebo
durante otros tres meses y al final
veremos qué es lo que sucede con sus
niveles de a1c y lo mismo va a pasar con
el otro grupo las personas que iniciaron
tomando el placebo después de tres meses
van a estar tomando la medicina y lo
valioso aquí es que debido a que todos
van a estar tomando la medicina durante
un periodo y ellos no van a saber en qué
periodo están tomando la medicina o el
placebo va a ser mucho menos probable
que tengamos alguna variable oculta como
la edad o la región geográfica o
comportamiento que cause algún
desequilibrio y modifique los resultados
dando unos resultados con sesgo esto es
algo interesante y como lo mencioné en
este vídeo y en el anterior
estas son diferentes formas de realizar
esto cuando construimos un experimento
obviamente tenemos experimentos en
medicina y también tenemos experimentos
en otros campos y es importante
considerar qué tipo de cosas son
prácticas de realizar y cuáles son las
que tienen la mejor oportunidad de
darnos información real
para ver si una variable explicativa
realmente tiene un efecto causal en la
variable explicada